une porte de sortie pour les céréales
bloqués dans les ports ukrainiens
la russie et l'ukraine s'apprête à
signer en turquie un accord sur la
reprise des exportations en mer noire si
demain nous attendons également pour
notre état des nouvelles en provenance
de turquie concernant le déblocage des
ports
une annonce très attendue car depuis le
début de l'invasion russe moscou a mis
en place un blocage maritime sur les
ports ukrainiens
résultat plus de 20 millions de tonnes
de céréales ils sont coincés notamment à
eau des stars et des dizaines de navires
sont à l'arrêt les répercussions sont
mondiales depuis le début de la guerre
les prix des denrées alimentaires ont
flambé et la famine menace plusieurs
pays en afrique notamment avec cet
accord négocié depuis plus de deux mois
l'onu espère sauver des millions de vies
comme vous le savez nous soulignons
depuis de nombreux mois la gravité de la
crise alimentaire dans le monde et c'est
une composante une grande composante de
cette crise donc si nous pouvons
résoudre ce problème nous pouvons
potentiellement sauver des centaines de
milliers voire des millions de personnes
des prix alimentaires hors de leur parti
en contre partie l'accord doit aussi
permettre un allègement des entraves sur
les exportations de céréales est
d'ancrer russe